tonight you are presenting best kids  right that's right  so your best on-screen kiss would be  will arnett I'm kidding no my best  on-screen kiss oh boy it would probably  be Emily Becca hearts okay okay all  right and why was it so good because  she's a good kisser I don't know I was  looking for some descriptions you know  I'm either girl you should always be  like a nervous energy when you kiss  somebody and we have known each other  and are such good friends before in such  a platonic normally so awkward for  hitted it's sort of it like and instills  and install some of these some of the  nerves that are needed for a kiss that  make a good kiss right yeah there you go